anyway uh Media Matters again Media
Matters again destroying Tucker he's
been taking L after well just kidding
they just make him look they're like
cooler Media Matters is becoming Tucker
Carlson's PR firm
I did I talked to her at Great length it
was actually pretty funny I said
you know
oh I said I she tried to get I was like
she's got a lot of liberals working over
there
and you know they see this as work and
we're the main
hey blue finger Now You're Gone Forever
now's not the day to test me so now
you're now not for no you know what yeah
forever bye
now you could [__] go [__] to
yourself I'm no [__] man like that's
crazy if you've got pronouns in your
Twitter bio you shouldn't work here find
out who the mean one is
because we can't trust you because
you're on the other side it's not him I
I'm known as the mean one because I
bottle it up bottle it up bottle it up
bottled up and then when you see me I
[__] explode on everyone but he's
actually mean all right he's like he's
always got his pressure release valves
are always open he's always just he's
constantly dumping toxic waste out there
me I dump it all at once
all right now I'm gonna Focus I'm gonna
I'm gonna stop building another chat now
I did I talked to her at Great length it
was actually pretty funny I said
you know
you know what's funny about this clip
too oh I said I she tried to get I was
like she's got a the the limp brush for
me is the funniest part no the the fact
that I just noticed it now but like
people with ear pieces and have the same
uh characteristics as somebody with
schizophrenia
it's literally the same thing yeah I was
talking to her the other day
and then they just like look off in the
distance and listen to a voice if you
ever watch a video of somebody with
schizophrenia it's the same thing and we
know that second when we're on the blaze
like Infowars you could hear them
talking in your ear like you know but
you don't hear so yeah you you do stop
because out of habit you want to hear it
you wanted so somebody who's really
sounds schizo try sitting around Sarah
Gonzalez she's got an earpiece in from a
producer she's talking to them getting
cues she has her husband on FaceTime in
another year she's talking to him on a
laptop and she's conversing with guests
and she looks insane sometimes right
because she'll just be like uh-huh and
did you get did you pick that up and
you're like did I pick one up
sorry
[Laughter]
liberal's working over there
and you know they see this is work and
we're the main
force on the other side and like that's
crazy if you've got pronouns in your
Twitter bio you shouldn't work here
because we can't trust you because
you're on the other side and she goes
well who and I said I'm not going to
name names because somebody asked in the
YouTube chat
um who's leaking this to Media Matters
fox has already come out and set a scene
to season the system Media Matters
saying that all these videos aren't
authorized blah blah blah blah right so
Fox is trying to be like look it's not
us my theory is is that these videos are
from around the same time that [__]
grossberg [__] was there and I I mean
again I'm not I have no idea this is I'm
no clue to have this information but it
would make sense that she did have
access to this she could have been
recording this for a while and then
giving it to them but the reason they're
not pinning it on her saying it was her
because she has an active lawsuit
yeah and honestly that could [__] it up
if it could be traced back to her and
that's also why I don't believe it's Fox
themselves because they haven't
negotiated his payout yet so they're
probably going like hey could you
[__] stop please we don't need him
thinking this is us you know what I mean
like if you were if we had to Sev like
separate with an employee right and they
were like we owed the money and we were
trying to work that out and then all of
a sudden [__] about them was getting
leaked from our private conversations
like off air like we would be telling
the leaker could you [__] stop dude
we got to pay this guy out and every
time you do this it's another million
could you [__] stop please right
okay lost cap now you're gone damn no no
no he's bringing the hammer today you're
gone for the live stream he keeps
posting the same thing the YouTube look
is include the training channel of it go
to go to YouTube and search revenge of
the sis it'll pop up or if you're such a
[__] fan of the show like I am I just
went to YouTube and it was bone marrows
yep I don't know who did it and I'm
definitely not going to cast aspersions
in someone unfairly just because you're
liberal doesn't mean you did this it
does mean you shouldn't work here and
Roger would never put up with this [__]
why would you do that
do you know what I mean
they see this as War it's like I'm not
that I'm an actual liberal like I'm
totally fine being like our makeup
artist is like a screaming they're
believing at her name so she for those I
don't know
because it makes it seem like it goes
this [__] and they believe that out this
car yeah this [__] [__]
um no but I'm not that way as you know
but they are that way and I said I'm not
ashamed of anything I said
but do you know what I mean Justin
if if you've got like that that horrible
guy who was just horrible who was Judge
jeanine's uh God I don't know what this
reference
for the show like I wish I knew what
they were saying on the other side
because what guy like did what they're
Janine like you know I have no idea uh
Roy said not to test them two by two is
whatever he wants Baba thanks clam
handles
I couldn't yeah that that guy it's like
a screaming left wing left wing why does
he work here what
you totally [__] over his anchor and
then we expect he's not gonna dick over
the network like I don't know I said
I kind of want to know a little bit more
detail like [__] her over in what way
I would love to know all of the gossip
that he knows yeah digged over in what
way you know
pick information on it but I would it's
just
yeah it's crazy I don't know all the
things that Tucker knows Tucker knows
terrible things that's a good point see
yeah
exactly exactly it's like I'm always
telling I'm telling my children like you
know what the truth is you can feel it
don't lie to yourself
so we know it's Janine we know it's
Judge Jeanine and this guy that [__]
her over but I mean a producer like I
don't know
she's so great
get ready
good evening
[__] that [__] [__] and throw four
three good evening
and welcome to tuckerland yeah they're
really dude I don't know man he's not
gonna keep surviving all these leaks
no no he's done and we were talking
about this off the air too it's like
it's not even like you're exposing
Tucker as like a lying hypocrite like
it'd be one thing if he was like oh I'm
all pro-trans I think we should give all
the kids shots and hormones and puberty
blockers we should do it for all of them
they'd be like wow what a hypocrite but
he's literally like these people are our
enemy and you're like nice based and
it's awesome and it's also like even
even if you're not looking at that way
it's also like everybody knows what it's
like to talk [__] about your boss or
people you work that are shitty like
it's a normal part of life right like
everybody goes oh does that [__] suck
that blah blah blah Did That to this
dude it's just normal you know what did
you think he was going to sit there
quietly like a robot